hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for this video or
I want to sort of follow up with my
earlier video on recognizing Supply
coming into the market via the footprint
chart and
you know it's it's important to have
software that helps you identify what's
taking place in the markets right and
you know that's one of the reasons why I
created my software the order flows
Trader software
um to help me identify special
situations in the market all right now
before I jump in if you enjoying my
videos be sure to subscribe to the
channel click that notification Bell so
you don't miss any new uploads and if
you find today's video helpful be sure
to hit that like button for me and leave
a comment sharing your biggest takeaway
I love hearing Traders comments and
feedback so your sport really does go a
long way in helping me get the
motivation and the idea is to create
more videos right I do create a lot of
videos based off of your comments
alright so let's go ahead and get
started on today's topic all right so
earlier today
I did a video and you know a couple
Traders uh reached out to me saying hey
Mike um you know it's a little confusing
trying to recognize you know a falling
Market with positive Delta right like
here red candle positive Delta red
candle positive Delta you know um you
know as we're going down here we got
negative Delta right which is what
you're expecting to see and then you
know further drops on positive Delta
right
positive Delta positive Delta positive
Delta positive Delta positive Delta
positive Delta into these new lows and
is there an easy way to look at it as
opposed to trying to sort of micromanage
what's taking place in the Delta what's
taking place in the footprint there is
right there is an answer there is a
solution to
um
everything in a sense now
on our order flows Trader software okay
well let's take a step back first okay
what causes
a market right or not Market a bar
a red candle
to have positive Delta
okay I'm going to just talk about red
candles today because this is a falling
Market
talking about Supply so if you haven't
watched earlier video that I posted up
earlier please take a look at it okay
here you have a red candle
but you got a couple buying imbalances
okay that's what's causing these
positive Deltas because you have Supply
coming into the market
what is supply it's people with
something to sell
right demand is buyers coming into the
market wanting to buy something Supply
is
you have a lot of inventory you want to
get rid of it whether it's in this case
gold whether it's I used apples earlier
um eggs
coats gloves underwear whatever whatever
you're selling right if you ever work
retail you understand about you know
supply and demand in a sense I would
hope so but you know that's why stores
have sales because they have a lot of
supply and they need to turn it over one
they need the money and two they got new
things coming in right seasons change
and so
when you start seeing these buying
imbalances that's to me like the first
clue if I got a red candle with buying
imbalances if this Market is if this bar
here is closing lower
and I got buying and balances I got to
start to think why is this bar closing
down when I've got aggressive buying in
here
okay well the reason why you got the
imbalances is because you have suppliers
in here right at 92 and a half at 92.40
at
91.90 I mean you got Supply at every
level but this is where you have those
imbalances those stick out
like a sore thumb
all right so I mean if you're looking at
a footprint you could identify it and
again depending on what sort of
imbalance that you use I use four to one
which is 400 percent
um you know I was driving in my car the
other day I was just seeing some random
YouTube video on on order flow the guy
is talking about 300 percent really it's
what you feel comfortable with I've used
400 for over a decade I'm fine with it
all right some people I know use
higher number right more than 400
percent
and again other Traders use 300
obviously the lower you go the more
imbalances you're going to get the
higher you go
the less imbalances you're going to get
and in the order flows Trader
software
we have a
feature on here
that's called
inverse volume imbalance okay
now
to enable it you click two so it's going
to be related to whatever imbalance
trigger that you have here
right I have 400 percent
now you got a couple options okay
well say a couple you got one option one
you got
imbalance cluster
all right if you just want to see if
there's one imbalance
an opposite imbalance and inverse and
balance so that would be a buying and
balance in a red candle or a selling a
balance on a green candle but again I'm
just talking about red candles today
you just want to highlight
um
well
the one right you change that to one if
then you could choose to highlight it
fixed or until tested okay
so we'll just keep it at one keep it
nice and simple so what it's going to do
it's going to highlight
every
inbound every buying a balance in a red
candle or every selling and balance on a
green candle okay because it's called an
inverse imbalance because it's the
opposite of what you're expecting in
this case the selling a balance on a
green candle would be demand
the buying a balance on a red candle
would be Supply
okay and just click apply and you can
see it's drawing out these zones and you
know on the way up
right I'm seeing the blue blue blue blue
right this was our low here at 850. okay
I got some demand I got some support
coming into this market then we get up
to the swing high now this bar up here
is quite interesting because you got
both buying and selling a balance at the
same level
plus the green candle so you know I'm
really focusing on you know sort of is
there support here okay and then it
doesn't go any higher now it starts
selling off okay now this is what gets
interesting
two selling imbalances right here stack
I'm sorry two stack buying imbalances
right one two
okay that's the Zone got another
buying a balance on a red candle here
you got two
here you got one you got another one
another one so now right this Market was
going up
with
bids you know decent bids that were
absorbing whatever aggressive selling
was coming in now the market is starting
to drop
right we sort of peek out up here or
start turning I mean you can just people
say how do you know the Market's turning
well
I've got one two three bars with Rising
Delta right it was positive positive
then negative more negative more
negative right so at that point I got to
be thinking this Market is changing
already because I've got
swing high and I'm starting to see
aggressive selling come in not only am I
seeing aggressive selling coming in here
from these three bars now I'm starting
to see strong passive selling coming in
that's absorbing whatever aggressive
buying is taking place that aggressive
buying
shuts off for whatever reason the market
drops the aggressive selling comes in
takes the market down here you got one
two three four cylinder balances
right but I'm just sort of focusing on
that inverse imbalance that imbalance
that's opposite what you expect to see
okay and you just see it on the way down
right we're coming down here's another
bar it's got two buying imbalances
here's another bar one buying imbalance
okay you know you gotta buying a balance
down here okay maybe the market could
bounce it doesn't it doesn't go any
higher goes inside more Supply coming to
the market right here okay Market
bounces up a little bit you get this one
green candle buying a balance on the top
okay maybe now this Market can rally
doesn't even go any higher
and then more Supply comes in in buying
a balance buying and balance buying and
balance buying and balance buying and
balance
so you know there's still a lot of
pressure on this market right down into
new lows
Supply Supply Supply Supply
right all the way down Supply Supply
Supply
okay then again you start to hit this
low this is sort of your last bit of
Supply coming to the market this 163
this 106. but now you're starting to see
you know the nice positive Deltas as the
Market's rallying but buying a balance
buying and balance okay so now you're
just not seeing that supply that you had
saw earlier after you get to this point
so that's you know one of the ways that
you can use the order flows Trader to
easily identify
when there's demand coming into the
market because what's Demand right
demand is not just aggressive buying
taking place but you still want you know
if you're looking for the market to go
up yes you want aggressive buying but
you also want strong bids coming in and
what's going to help you identify that
is imbalances selling imbalances on
those green candles
here here just as if a market is
pounding lower
what you like to see that is very nice
to see it and again
taking a step back to talking about sort
of risk management in your Trading you
know understanding that there is still
Supply in the market right because
anytime you're making this new lows are
you thinking if you're short you're
thinking okay this is it you know it's a
green candle I got a cover but you still
see Supply in that market maybe you
won't cover maybe you'll give the trade
more room to run
right I mean
you know every trade you still got to
manage it
and for me I always Advocate that
using order flow helps you manage the
trades that you're in
right because if you're if you're
writing this all the way down to these
new lows down here
not really any reason to buy off of you
know these two green candles so you're
not gonna you know want to cover it
necessarily off of you know a red candle
that keeps making new lows you know
you're going to start recognizing oh hey
you know what I got a green candle here
okay I see aggressive buying coming in
and I see some decent passive buying
also taking place to absorb whatever
aggressive selling there is going in you
know at the lows here okay then you
start getting in here and by this point
you know if you haven't covered already
you're starting to see you know decent
bids coming in right and a sign of a
decent bid is a green candle with a
selling imbalance
so this is you know the area that you'd
cover you know be you know the the last
the last place but you know maybe you
covered it off of this bar here
definitely off of this bar already
you know that's how being in a
trade you could manage it using the
order flow
all right so that wraps up this video on
the inverse imbalance to see Supply
coming into the market and I hope you
guys enjoy this video and again if you
find my videos helpful to you
be sure to subscribe to the channel if
you haven't already you know leave some
comments below I love reading your
comments I love hearing success stories
I love hearing how people
um comment here because I do get a lot
of emails from from Traders saying Mike
you know your videos have helped me
become
um you know profitable I've been
struggling with my trading you know
things like that you know that's
heartwarming that's why I do these
videos is you know to help Traders right
help them understand what's taking place
in the markets I mean we're living in
this great information age where now we
have computers that do all this stuff
you know when I started all you had was
just the simple price bar you know cqg
there's this ugly orange color chart
you know that was it now you got all
these colors going on you know the
trading is very visual as well
um you know so it it's just fascinating
the the information age that we're
living in it's all right everyone thanks
again for watching my channels watching
my videos you know thanks again for
being part of my order flow Community
your support is appreciated and I'll see
you guys in the next video take care